go figure the old you'll get a better  job because of it adage is also evolving  see what's cool about this is college  works for so many people and it used to  work for a lot more people it's awesome  how epic College was in the 60s 70s 80s  and 90s as a leverage to a career but  the internet came along and completely  fundamentally changed everything people  are struggling to understand that the  mature internet is here and what that  does is allows people to create resumes  in a different way that isn't just  predicated on the way that school works  and the peoples the people whose brain  works for that school system are then  considered smart I've just you know seen  way too many people that have gone to  Great schools that don't translate to  the real world and vice versa and some  bad students suck in the real world too  and vice versa it's just a proxy